hello everyone we are with John cotton
from the circling Institute hey we just
got to do a good vodcast together it was
a great great conversation and we're
gonna circle each other now so as you
guys if you hadn't checked out the
content before and check out there's
tons of videos on circling circling is a
practice of connection between two
people intimate connection between two
people and we'll be showcasing that John
will be circling me first and will be
kind of peeling back these layers that
we build up on top especially with
technology being such an influence on
that as well and then later we'll do the
reverse so I will circle John and
there'll be a separate piece of content
so you're looking out for that anything
before flip this guy over go about 25
minutes or so of of circling in a couple
minute debrief afterward
any thoughts before we start it's time
in let's dive in yeah yeah ready I'm
ready
like you closing your eyes
how are you doing like house how's your
heart
I think the reason I ask is
he's like you occur to me as a so fairly
busy and a little bit stressed yet
passionate like happy very relational
but I just watch you going at a high
speed so I'm just wondering how how in
touch with you are your heart how's it
doing how's that part of your life
and and how was it to hear what I just
said like no accurate is an yeah very
accurate very accurate
lots of high-speed passion about what is
being built but also the recognition
that that also comes with lots of absent
flows
ups and downs vicissitudes try to not
dwell too long in the neuroses then
they're worth yeah yeah it digs it digs
hard at the heart and soul if if we
dwell in it too long so I move on and I
try and peel the layers back feel and
move on the reintegration and the
completion
though the heart the heart has some you
know longing for is it is it possible to
find someone that is on the same kind of
level as I am about both IQ EQ matter
and energy IQ if you want someone
intelligence intelligent he wants
someone who's emotionally intelligent
like they they can get what's happening
with you and the third one was was what
matter and energy energy also want him
to be smarter than me I want them to be
attractive like there's just so many
like these wants right and I'd rather
not invest my time right now going and
trying to seek my yes I'd rather invest
my time and building out what's going on
because I think he'll naturally
gravitate more of what I'm seeking I
don't even know if I'm subscribing to
the one partner forever mentality yeah
so that there's a whole subscription
that's been going on the humanities has
been subscribing so yeah here and like
you have a lot of expansive beliefs
right about like where you want your
attention and what's possible and and
what you might like to explore in terms
of possibility in a relationship itself
and yet the first thing though I heard
was there's desire there's somebody you
wanting somebody who
who is your equal your partner has the
same level of both breadth and depth
yeah and they can challenge you they can
help you yeah and you and like you want
the chemistry you wanted like the
tragedies you wanted you want to feel
drawn to them the deliciousness of it
yes and then you sort of immediately
went to and I don't know that that's
possible right now so I don't know that
I it was almost like I don't know that I
want to feel that right now because it
might put me into it might take away
from ya my my creativity somehow or
something could also augment the
creativity yeah yeah and then I
remembered before you mentioned like
neurosis said enough they're two
completely different things like longing
it's like I don't want to maybe I don't
wanna I can touch into that a little bit
and then I gotta I gotta go off to
create and then you said a similar thing
about it's like there's that whatever
that box is whatever is in there pretty
Pandora's box so I'd like just peel the
layers off they get through it and then
I go go on like yeah I would say the
neurosis has to do more with the ups and
downs of the business the ups and downs
of executing something of utility into
the world than it does about the longing
in the heart although it is a very
strange how those two things actually do
relate at times as well I do feel that
way almost like how you how you go into
them and how long you stay in them and
and then pop out it seems like a similar
process somehow
yeah also there's this there's this
strangeness to my my family like my mom
and my uncle who are very smart but also
close mind at that time since a way that
I'm thinking and the way that I'm be
educating myself
they're very conventional in terms of
like wanting to like get a college
degree and getting like a PhD and like
this type of stuff is very important for
the world and I'm like I probably have
the one of the best education in the
world by doing this show getting to sit
across from the diverse smartest at
times people and it's difficult to
convey that in a way that unlocks their
open-mindedness and so you know at times
there's feelings of you know mom saying
you know I'm very proud of you and stuff
and that other times it's like you know
we want you to finish your college
degree and I'm like oh then like those
things are at times contradicting yeah I
notice I feel protective of you and I
got III appreciate just your your
radical willingness to walk the like an
unexplored path
it's in service of
not only your own exploration but it
just seems to be a profound carefree for
humankind somehow and what you're doing
and what you're wanting to deliver
that's that's a lot of what I've gotten
from our talks before them that makes me
feel like you're aware of me and because
the journey is sudden it's unexplored
path and it's an for me it's an
unexplored path for many it's already
been explored and it's the
unconventional one and I want to do
though and I will really want to do
what's unconventional I think there's a
lot of wisdom in the unconventional and
in the unique and potentially even that
is where creativity lies the most is in
the unique and in the unconventional and
I want to be at the forefront now I
constantly want to be at the edge of
creativity because it's expanding my
awareness to interesting places but
coming back to the heart and coming back
to feeling because I typically go very
intellectual times like this I love that
you caught it you know I typically go
super intellectual at times like this I
want to I don't actually be with these
feelings because these feelings of like
longing or desire for both like a
partner if that's even a partner
structure so interesting we've had
friends that have been teaching us about
the like every week we don't we don't
were not married we're kind of interests
a union like an agreement between us
where we just every month we revisit
I'll give to the the every month every
month we revisit the way that you know
that how are the logical things that I
said I was gonna do how are the
emotional things that I said I was going
to do how are they for you and that's
the kind of thing that I'm probably even
more interested in rather than the
conventional style and then there's that
longing or desire for maybe something
like that but then there's also this
longing and desire for maybe like my you
know my uncle especially to like you
know he
shows love in these very interestingly
different ways than it conventionally
and and my mom also just like maybe a
little bit of like like recognition that
maybe like what's going on is actually
important because I think part of it has
to do with that whole like
entrepreneurial journey like there's no
money in this you know there's and I'm
like and I'm like you know the the
impact the I don't think they really get
this about me because the things they
find it strange but like the impact that
I want to leave on the planet and
doesn't require me earning money
personally like to have this earned
money to be able to continue fueling
itself is the most important thing to me
and then my name being written on it
doesn't mean anything to me that you can
erase my name you can erase as long as
the impact on the civilization is for
the betterment and so that that's
strange to them and so because of that I
feel a very big disconnect because their
constant like you know money's very
important you know it's always been very
important it will always be very
important and so that's a yeah so I'm
hearing like there's a there's a
yearning in your heart for a partner but
and that's sort of future-oriented
even though it's it's alive right now
and there's a yearning for to be
accepted and understood by your family
which is sort of like your past in a way
bringing an you present but
just sort of both coming together and
and it seems like when you when you feel
into those you like you said before you
feel them for a moment and then you kind
of go off into like okay I felt them but
now like what do I have to do like I'm
I'm wondering like - yeah like do those
like - those - those desires - those
parts of you get their full expression
like what's what's it like to feel the
desire for love what's it like to feel
the desire for your mom and your uncle's
understanding and acceptance yeah that's
a really good question what is that
feeling of desire like yeah yeah it's a
feeling of the desire for love and
understanding like for you yeah I have
no idea Wow yeah I have no idea at all
this like the first time I'm probably
ever like really trying to understand
what this feels like
that's happened let's feel into that
together have no idea so I have no idea
like I have this desire for love
have no idea what it actually feels like
Wow so then like I'm sensing that like
there's all these thoughts about what
it'll mean or what it'll take for me to
get there
I like the NSI feeling today I go but
I'm not sure how I'm gonna recognize the
feeling like how will I know when it's
there how will I know when I have it
maybe part of it feels like a void but
part of it also feels like a process of
growth and so then it doesn't feel like
void in exploration of growth and
exploration what's the growth in there
the growth is like take these feelings
of longing and desire and you kind of
integrate them into your existence yeah
and I think that helps a lot with just
day-to-day yeah
but I have no idea what why do I have no
idea what it feels like to have a desire
for love and understanding
so how does it live in you like right
now as we're talking about it feels like
a big unknown huge unknown and what does
unknown feel like it feels like
something in the in the chest that is
like here yeah like maybe like this is
kind of like like what is the the word
that comes to mind is what so what is it
like a seeking is it a feeling of being
lost is it just like a pure wanting but
not knowing exactly what you want is it
a sense of denial like what and what you
tease out like that I think it's a I
think it might be what it might be a
feeling of what what is this feeling and
then it's a why why does it exist why
haven't I voiced this feeling to other
people mm-hmm and is that frustration
its exploration exploration yeah its
exploration like a searching in part of
it is frustration part of it's like why
is our cultural fabric not able to
elicit feelings like this more
frequently yeah and so that's maybe
where the frustration is
it's a frustration that feels palpable
like I noticed my whole like just
sitting over here my whole body relaxed
when I heard that because it just felt I
just felt like true like ah like I feel
like I can land in that with you before
I felt like I was on a little bit of a
trade afraid a freight train of the
story I'm like let's get to all these
creations which felt exciting yet I felt
I was i I was felt a little disconnected
from from you from where I think I felt
connected and wanting to feel even more
connected it's for the first moment I
have my how's your heart I have more
about the heart this this feeling that I
have about kind of how strange it is to
have other people that I'm working on a
project with and how difficult it is to
like feel like I care about them like
they are myself like they're part of me
and part of my family and that I love
them so dearly without it coming off as
inauthentic to where I may be yeah do
you
I hope that the way that I communicate
about the vision of like erasing the
name from everything and just having the
impact on civilization because if they
come on board for that reason then the
feeling is mutual authentication why
people are interested in coming on board
with what's going on then then I feel
like maybe there can be a disconnect but
I think you were talking about this
earlier when the emotion initially rises
up for somebody to voice the emotion
immediately I think that's really
important to be like this is how I'm
feeling and I'm calling you out on your
[ __ ] or that I am feeling that love
and that trueness and like being able to
say those things help keep people in
check I think better and I think I need
to be you know kept in check because oh
the truth is a lot of what I do is is
schmoozing like it's it's it's it is
it's schmoozing that's the truth
it's you know it's telling everybody
that what they're doing is very
important and that's just that's the
truth that's the raw real truth and even
though it's true that somebody that is
working on a decentralization project is
is important in their right as well as
someone that's working on a project of
mapping the brain or of intimate
connection between people I need to be
able to tell someone maybe one of those
three people or one outside of them that
like hey what you're working on isn't
important to me and that's why I'm not
going to work with you on this but keep
doing what you're doing
we're counting on so there's a
distinction you're making
and being able to be authentic and real
with what you're feeling and and not be
shy from delivering it one way or
another like either this is resonating
but this is not resonating and that's
important to the selfless work that
you're doing in the world and you want
people who are like onboard with that
like like they're not in it for the
power or the money or the name they're
in it actually to make a profound impact
on the world and that and that turns you
on like that that's alive for you and
yeah way that's that I think what I'm
hearing you sort of tie into it's like
that alone feeds your heart yeah I just
didn't know yeah that you're doing that
there's such a deep connection with
yourself like when someone grabs me and
tells me that the names don't matter
yeah and get to the goal and do it for
the world do it together for the world
that feeling has never happened for me
and when that does happen I think that
will really unlock what is peeled back
from the layers and and there's there's
a there's a little bit more I just want
to say there's a little bit more which
is that it makes it difficult for other
people because I say so much about like
hey what you're doing is important what
you're doing is important like that it
makes it difficult for people to be like
is this guy actually saying this cuz he
actually thinks that way and so I need
to you know be more real I need to be
more real and you figure out how to
properly be real without you know
putting people into suffering or pain
yeah yeah and so so there's there's that
and there's the longing and desire for a
partner and then there's a longing and
desire for my mom and uncle
then there's this radical like dream and
so it just it you know it's only it's
only scratching the surface of it all
but I I want to sprinkle all these
different things in this process of you
circling me it seems like the the impact
you want to make on the world and what
that takes and the fact that you're
willing to be selfless which means like
you're putting that even before yourself
it seems like that has that takes so
much energy and time and commitment and
effort and passion yeah and I notice I
I can't help but love you for that and I
imagine a lot of people loving you for
that and wish they'd say it yeah and at
the same time yeah yeah I wish they'd
say I felt the sadness in that yeah you
turned your head like this and someone's
like you sunk I felt my heart sunk a
little bit and because I think where my
attention started where it still is is
like his his Alan's heart getting fed
and nourished personally yeah surely
purely personally not for the effect
that you're having in the world but
purely for your for your own nourishment
is nourishment I don't want it to
nourish the ego it's more about
nourishing the heart and the heart can't
just go you know work in a cave on all
this stuff you're working amongst other
people and you know the feeling of you
know and I think that is part of
something that I try and do for people
as I try and nourish their heart along
the way and tell them that even though
it's a smaller aspect of the impact that
you're doing in this certain thing it's
still important so keep up the good work
we are counting on you and to hear that
in return like somebody grabbing you and
going like you're doing insanely
important things and putting their hand
on your heart and going like keep up the
good work and like maybe a kiss on the
forehead a huge long hug like a minute
of just hug like crying crying
that stuff is is just slacking for the
nourishment and it was actually great I
was able to have some time with my mom
so yeah sounds like what you described
this is part of what you're something
you're really longing for my kind of
more consistent basis and you and you're
not you're not getting that
is that true
yeah like the stoic and me is like it's
not as important as the actual impact
but the emotion in me the heart in me
that energy is saying yeah get some of
that along the way get that nourishment
along the way it will help a lot and so
that's I just but the wilderness and you
speaking and it's and it's like you are
remarkable at giving that to other
people I see you do that all the time
I hope it comes off authentic and if it
doesn't I need to be checked as well me
it totally does I mean you're so
validating I hope you check me along the
way though to make sure that I can you
know keep doing it real yeah I was able
to pass some time with my mom last thing
where you know just like you know
cuddling my mom just like hugging her or
hugging me or heads like really close to
each other and probably finally at that
point where I'm just like we don't even
need to talk like we were just silent
for minutes on end and we talked for a
bit and silent for a minutes on and they
were just holding you shall i caress
each other and you know just that
feeling of of time going by holding my
mom Wow yeah so good
when I know she's not forever I know
she's not forever and I'm not forever
and that feeling of her smell and the
way that she says loving words to me
it's not forever and so you know I joke
around by telling her that mom I'm gonna
put a voice recorder every time you say
soul anishka moisten it some way it's
about you do yet see Baba shy or these
words of like you're my son you're my I
love you you know
adore you then I'm gonna record them and
I'm gonna put them on a little like
hopefully when technology gets good
enough but I'm on a clone of mom you
know but so so anyway I yeah yeah if you
say that I'm just I'm just taking in
like a feeling imagining I'm you know
I'm just taking in a feeling like I'm
I'm being held I'm getting a section I'm
being loved up I'm being cared for I'm
getting I'm getting so much more than
that one minute and they kiss on the
forehead it's like like I'm I'm getting
all the love in the world in one moment
yeah and it's and it's lasting
I notice you say sliding up what's it
actually like for you
you´d speaking about lasting love
sending that back my way makes me light
up lasting love lasting love let's um
let's let's debrief on kind of like what
happened in the circle so usually the
[Laughter]
that's something that I think Ron
actually taught me really well the
director-producer is just like you know
be be like be real on that like it's the
end so it's the end gonna get there and
end there and you know and treat it that
way and make it known for other people
and so sometimes I'm really bad at that
so I'm getting better at that and I need
to listen to him more cuz he's a very
wise person and can I just ask like one
thing as we actually end yeah so like
what just happened for you in this and
and and like what was the journey would
ya soon so that we finish the process of
the actual circle but then there's a
process of debriefing and that's kind of
what we're going through right now which
Jon just asked me about you know the
journey that we took like what happened
for me I tried to waterfall out as much
as I could I tried to waterfall out as
much of like what I'm feeling as
possible because I'm not like I don't
want to stay at the surface level of how
I'm feeling I want a waterfall out the
deepest buckets you know there's this
bucket of longing for love there's this
bucket of longing for mom and uncle
there's this bucket of longing for the
vision to come true there's this bucket
of water fall waterfall I just want to
give it all and then and they're all you
know there they all are they're all
strangely somewhat similarly impacting
my heart and my energy but also
differently impacting my heart and
energy
I want to ask how that was for you
I feel like I got another slice of your
world I feel a little bit more connected
to you just so much love for you there's
so much love for you yeah likewise
and I mean yeah I appreciate what you're
doing in the world and I don't even mean
to have a tone of voice of minimizing
that I mean I think it's extraordinary
remarkable and so few people have their
attention on this and like the way you
described your like being on the edge
reminded me of like the way Einstein
would describe like riding a wave of
energy to learn about light or so and
separate from anything else you're doing
even if you weren't doing any of it
and it's like who you are he's like
being around you yeah and and and I was
such as was really touched by your
longing I just I felt I felt that deep
desire just like you wanting something
for yourself that's separate from your
impact on the world yeah and you know
and I felt really in touch with that and
if anything I like I've you're one I
felt a desire to be with that more I
felt a desire to just sit in there and
it's just feel the desire whether or not
there's any belief of whether that can
happen now the desire just seemed so
pure and so innocent and so real and I
just wanted to be with that part of you
more I'm happy to be with that feeling
more in our next conversations let's
let's let's do so because that
nourishment is very important so yeah
thank you John yeah thank you thank you
it's beautiful thank you
and what are we allowed to hug yeah
let's are of course let's switch to the
heart side
you